[Music]
[Applause]
Doris Burke Hall of Fame broadcaster
ESPN analyst and I believe two-time Big
East
uh All-Star all-conference as a point
guard is that right Doris was it
two-time
so long ago I have no recollection oh
don't be so modest you sound like a
joker here being so modest there uh who
plays point guard the way you did who
plays point guard in the NBA the way you
did it Providence oh shoot uh you know I
don't have a great comparison what I
will tell you is I have sympathy for any
point guard who's a scoring point guard
with no jumper so my game Dan was this
out in transition my handle was
exceptional I could get absolutely
anywhere but but
you know those players who um coaches
just back off and give a pushing to 60.
that was me
you were you were Rajon Rondo before
Rondo
bing bing and Jeff Van gundy's always
like how did how and this is Jeff saying
that we laugh all the time how are you a
white point guard and you can't shoot
uh you're Doug Gottlieb
I don't know all time
incredible teammates incredible
you know had it not been for that I
wonder like you know the game gives you
such Joy Dan and those I only have fond
memories as a player so we see a lot of
catchers who become managers I don't
know if there's a correlation point
guards as broadcasters or coach like you
see the game differently at a different
angle and the same with catchers uh is
there any correlation that being a point
guard how it helps you see a game as
you're broadcasting yeah I do think you
know you are responsible to know
um every position on the floor you know
where the four of the five is going to
be at any particular moment and then um
you know generally speaking the balls in
your hand so you should be communicating
with everybody and uh so I do think
there is a little bit of a correlation I
guess similar to a quarterback in
football right who or what decides the
NBA finals
oh boy
um you know so many things are going to
happen over the next seven games I can't
wait to see the journey what what
intrigues me about this matchup one of
the things that intrigues me is you have
two superstars who love to empower the
people around them and you know Eric
spolster has talked about Dan not being
able to quantify the influence that
Jimmy has on the group
um you know I had a vote for the Eastern
Conference Finals MVP and when I texted
the uh person at the leeco I was
supposed to text it too my first text
was Caleb Martin that young man had
played so great
and maybe a minute and a half to go in
the game I changed my mind and yeah I
did and it was hard like that vote if
you saw it it was so close and I still
don't know if I made the right decision
but ultimately there's that intangible
leadership confidence that Jimmy Butler
sort of
you know it permeates the whole roster
and we
underestimate Miami to our Peril right
they just spent seven games disavowing
us of the notion that Boston was the
better team and then jokic to access
yokich's brilliant stand he had to come
to grips with something that was
probably uncomfortable for him a couple
years ago and that was there would be
times where he would have to flex a
little bit as a scorer and show off the
array he had offensively his first
instinct is to pass and to make the guys
feel good around him but I just love
that you have two superstars
um who want to play the right way and
who want to make their teammates around
them feel really good I love that
fair comparison to have Joker and Tim
Duncan mention in the same sentence
why that's uh I think so you know I
think uh you know the vision with which
jokic plays the game the feel the
execution of these touch passes the
Absurd passes where he's you know
leading people into spaces
um as his teammate Aaron Gordon who
yoker Joker described as the soul of our
team he said he's a savant uh so I would
say Tim was savant-like maybe in
different fashion uh but yo you know
Nicola is a savant and I and here's the
thing you know I hope in the course of
the the broadcast people get a sense for
who this man is you know he wears his
wedding ring tied around his shoe you
know the first eyes he's looking to seek
out when he finishes a game is his
daughter his family is clearly important
to him he's not at all involved in the
NBA lifestyle it's just something so
appealing about the person Nicola could
say the same about Jimmy you know Jimmy
wants to play tennis and he wants to
travel the world in the off season he
gets his work in but these are two men
with with the lives that are very rich
around the game too can you teach what
Joker sees on the floor
no I don't I don't believe so and it's
funny there's that great line where Mike
Malone was talking to him and I love
that Mike said
um anybody who tells you they knew what
Joker was going to be is full of baloney
there's just no way he showed up at
summer league 300 pounds in out of shape
and and you have to admire Dan he is not
the two-time MVP if he doesn't change
the level of physical conditioning an
82-game schedule but most particularly
this march to June is brutal physically
and mentally
um but I don't think you teach it he
jokes about being a fat point guard he's
like coach I was a fat point guard as a
kid goes back to that point guard uh uh
point you made earlier Dan you see it
and feel it differently from that
position can you teach what Jimmy Butler
brings Miami
at the start of this the series and I'm
going to be honest with you I expected
Boston to win but one of the things I
said before game one of the Eastern
Conference Finals was Boston I mean
Miami is the most physically and
mentally tough team in the league and
coached by a top 15 coach in the 76-year
history of the game Eric Spoelstra I
believe is now six and one
um in the Eastern Conference Finals
um you can't teach it the other thing
you look at the growth and I do think
these players you know Miami couldn't
make a shot in the regular season Dan
couldn't make a shot they are first in
percentage Duncan Robinson gave Vincent
and mostly Caleb Hart have been shot
makers I do think they have to do it
again how about Caleb Martin undrafted I
know we've made a big deal of it in the
Eastern Conference Finals a year ago Dan
they wouldn't check the kid they
wouldn't guard them they gave him 15
feet of space and he said hey they that
well that was appropriate I was not
prepared for the moment but shame on me
if I'm not prepared the second time and
that young man to deliver the way he did
in that that series just pretty cool how
do you think this plays out
I think it's going to be a longer series
Than People expect I I am curious to see
how Miami feels
um there were points at which I thought
uh Jimmy fatigue I thought you saw that
in the middle of a series Kyle Lowry
um him as well
um you know Eric spoelster maintains
that patent me is healthy but remember
they shut him down for five weeks I
think that Championship experience he
brings is significant I think you saw
that in in the Eastern Conference and
apostolically in the in the prior rounds
uh you do get the extra rest but we are
in Denver I think it's it's at least six
games I will be surprised if Denver
doesn't win uh but I think it's going to
be longer and harder than people think
talking to Doris Burke ESPN NBA analyst
she'll be on the call ESPN radio for the
NBA Finals best player you saw this year
was who
well I voted Joelle embiid MVP and I'm
going to say this 100 and I believe it
to my core when Joelle is in shape and
he's engaged and he's healthy he can be
every single night the most influential
player on both ends of the floor he has
to decide now after getting the MVP does
he want to follow up and be great again
and now advance to a place um where he
isn't but a very close second for me was
Nicola jokic I went one two and I will
tell you those two positions you know
alternated All Seasons so
um those two guys would you keep James
Harden in Philly
well with Nick nurse I think it it
becomes more problematic because Nick is
a guy
um who wants to play aggressive
defensively he wants you locked in for
the full 24. think about it Dan in the
2019 finals he ushers in what we see
more and more of the boxing ones the
triangle and twos the switching defenses
the you know I say a lot of times
increasingly it's getting hard to play
in the NBA if you don't think it on a
high level on both ends of the floor uh
and Nick demands a lot the other thing
he does is he plays his starters a lot
of minutes at least if you look at what
he did in Toronto so I don't know these
are the hard choices it's the thing I
understand the least but I will say this
I don't think teen success in any sport
is is simply a matter of the collection
of talent the pieces have to fit there
has to be some chemistry you have to
work well you see it over and over
curious to see if Denver wins does that
have any influence in how teams are put
together or the way you know people
build their their organizations they
they drafted well they were patient uh
they waited for Jamal to get healthy
says something organizationally to me
anyway so I brought this up a couple of
times Tatum and brown don't compliment
each other they're sort of the same
player whereas Jamal and Joker
complement each other A.D and LeBron
complement each other I think you can go
down the the list of teams when they're
successful you have those players who
compliment each other that's what kind
of concerns me with Boston Jalen Brown's
a wonderful player
and they could have easily gone back to
the finals but would you you know give
them a max deal would you you want to
have that pair for the next five years
right I think that's the complicating
Factor here and I I was thinking about
this last week
um because of you could have two guys
locked up at 600 million and it sounds
like the way the salary structure is
it's going to be a high penalty to try
to do that and you know Jalen Brown's
old weaknesses came to bear again his
lack of a left hand his turnover issues
forcing shots at inappropriate times but
then Dan I started to Rifle through Well
everybody's talking about Damian Lillard
I don't know off the top of my head how
how old Damian is he's coming off in a
phenomenal year
but you you how many times do you see
Superstars Acquired and it not pay
dividends over and over and over and
over again it's these are these are hard
decisions and when I tried to come up
with names to replace Jalen Brown I'm
thinking oh boy
you know that's not as easy as you think
it is yeah I had somebody who's involved
in this situation they said you know
you've got to get these guys paying them
is not the the hard part as much as it
is getting the guy and that's why he
said that he thinks the Celtics are
going to resign him what do you do if
you're the Lakers in the off season
oh boy well you're you're re-signing
Reeves I mean he just is a better player
than anybody ever expected his ability
to handle and pick and roll and really
absorb the responsibility takes so much
weight off of uh off of LeBron I think
you no matter what you do you need
um Defenders and Shooters around LeBron
and Anthony Davis it's always about
space
um you know I think one thing that I was
really locked into all year Dan was how
much of a struggle LeBron's jump
shooting was I mean he could not make a
shot and I kept pressing Darvin Ham on
what's going on here early on in the
year he was saying it's the kinds of
shots he's being forced to take there's
no space the Russell Westbrook Dynamic
was brutal
um and then he said Doris remember how
old he is these these things are harder
now
um so a lot I I thought the moves they
made at the deadline were critical uh
rui hachimura if he can sustain that
level able to play I prioritize him as
well he's big he's fast he's long he can
often supported he made shots but to me
it's always about spacing around LeBron
and A.D I just thought LeBron started to
show his age by settling for the jumper
because I mean all you need is Michael
Jordan to acknowledge that if he played
LeBron LeBron would be able to go right
on him and he couldn't stop him
Michael's words it takes so much energy
to try to get to the hoop and get fouled
and he's not a great foul shooter and
he's not a great jump shooter but it
just felt like that's what you do as you
get older you don't attack uh you know
the rim anymore and that's what I saw
when people say oh you know he's not
showing his age and I said yes he shows
it every game by settling for those jump
shots and he knows he's not a good jump
shooter
yeah and I'm curious to see what his
approach is and the reason they wanted
to play fast is exactly that reason and
it's different in the regular season
right you can run on teams you can get
out a transition it's at the most
important time of year where defenses
are locked in and they say well we're
not going to let you get to your comfort
zones one two and three you're gonna
have to get to four five and six and
we're going to expose every weakness and
so yeah this goes to the what what
everybody expected in Los Angeles Dan
and that was that Anthony Davis would be
the primary option and the leader in all
of those things and that hasn't come to
fruition whether it's personality or
health or whatever it is that's
contributed to these last couple seasons
for A.D and that's the mystery because
I've said many times he was The Greek
Freak before The Greek Freak he did
everything offensively defensively could
shoot he had a handle
and then all of a sudden he was nice in
New Orleans and then you play those big
games in a big Spotlight and then we see
who these guys really are and that's
what's frustrating with A.D is he's one
of the top 75 players of all time but
there are times I don't know he's on the
floor
yeah yeah and a ghost and so this is
what draws into sharper Focus for me
what you said about A.D draws into
sharper focus a guy like Jimmy Butler
whose numbers in the playoffs rise his
productivity as a score as an assist guy
as you know efficiency it takes
something different at this time of year
to succeed
um and this is why you know jokic you
know the criticism and why you know some
people say well I'm not going to vote
for him three-time MVP whatever the case
may be hadn't had to be success in the
playoffs
that argument's laid to rest now he's
appeared in the finals and a very good
chance to to do it but I I would say
this to you I saw I don't know who was
debating it uh but somebody was saying
something it's Jimmy Butler a Hall of
Fame guy if he should win the the NBA
Finals I I'd put that I I was interested
I haven't given it much thought I don't
know if it's something strikes you
immediately about that for you
well if factor in college and did he
have a remarkable college career
um oh and so he's bounced around with
these teams he finally got his team in
Miami you know Philly wanted what Tobias
Harris instead of him and what happened
in Minnesota and then Chicago
it feels like he's he's pretty down he's
on the doorstep he's he's right there to
be a Hall of Famer But It's Tricky I got
into this conversation with Reggie
Miller the other day I said is Al
Horford a Hall of Famer because he won
two titles in college
so if I factor in that then is he a Hall
of Famer he's part of a championship
team I don't know
does it feel to you I mean I'm just you
know feeling like I feel like almost NBA
success seems like it's more important
for Hall of Fame credential I'd have to
like do a deep dive or have somebody
from research at ESPN to a deep dive
it's a great point you know you forget
about the back-to-back titles uh the
appearances in the in the Eastern
Conference Finals it's a great question
great debate who knows I know I know uh
hey great talking basketball with you
and uh always yeah and the older you get
the better you were when you were in
college just you know that's what I
always say and you're wearing your
Providence you got your Providence gear
on don't you yeah if it's free it's if
it's free it's for me then I'll take
three uh have fun Doris thank you very
much have fun tonight
thanks man that's uh Doris Burke Hall of
Fame broadcaster she'll be on the call
by the way
first woman to be assigned NBA Finals
game analyst role on any platform radio
or TV